This lesson is about the policies and
programs the US Federal Government
has created
to encourage the adoption of electronic
records and other health IT tools.
And to provide incentives for
their use in ways that will improve
the quality and efficiency of care.
Healthcare providers have had
a financial incentive to do
all available tests and
procedures once someone is sick.
And have had little or no incentive
to keep their patients well.
Until recently there was
no incentive except for
special situations like HMOs
that we discussed in lesson one,
to invest money in health IT systems
that might actually reduce income
by helping avoid unnecessary or
duplicative tests and procedures.
These incentives are often referred to
as pay for performance, or P for P.
In the typical P for P system, providers
are rewarded for doing tests and
procedures that scientific evidence
suggests are beneficial for
either managing or
preventing chronic disease.
For diabetes this might be an annual
blood test called hemoglobin A1C
that we'll discuss later on.
It might also be screening their
patients for obesity and smoking and
counseling them to lose weight or quit.